alright there was a question here what
happened to the dinosaurs well gosh so
far as people can tell the first point
is for a long time
died dinosaurs were only comparatively
recently discovered people had thought
you know there might be dragons and
things and they'd been sort of stories
about how there were dragons but nobody
really knew about that and then in the
1800's 150 years ago or something
people really started systematically
finding fossils and they found fossils
that were kind of reminiscent of dragons
and those were fossils of dinosaurs and
it was only only in the 1800s that sort
of the idea that there had been these
large creatures that lived a long time
ago
really sort of emerged and it became
clear that the dinosaurs had lived up
until about 65 million years ago and
then they disappeared and for a long
time when I was a kid it was like why
had the dinosaurs disappeared answer
because the dinosaurs are reptiles they
called blooded etcetera etcetera
etcetera long people had said had come
the mammals and the mammals were just a
much better
a collection of critters and we're of
course mammals and it's like we were the
winners the dinosaurs were the losers
and it was just like the mammals there
were all kinds of stories about the
mammals ate the dinosaur eggs etc etc
that's why the dinosaurs died out that
was the story and there were these
people
I knew that them they were physicists
who said actually there's another
possibility the possibility is maybe an
asteroid hit the earth and and caused
the earth to get really cold for a
couple of years because it threw a bunch
of dust up into the atmosphere and that
covered the Sun and things got really
cold and the dinosaurs died out as a
result of that and at the beginning this
looked like a completely crazy theory
because it seemed like you know why
would anybody think that would happen
and it was was just all all look very
implausible and then what was discovered
was that all over the earth there's this
tiny layer I think it's a Veridian
osmium and I'm not don't completely
remember of a very of a rare
Chemical rare element that exists as a
little little layer that you can find if
you dig down in rocks and you find so
when you know when rocks form they tend
to be in these layers where the most
recent rocks are on top and the earlier
rocks are underneath so you can get kind
of an idea of what's how old by sort of
digging down and seeing what layer you
hit what at and so what happened is the
there's this layer all over the earth of
these unusual it's unusual element that
HAP that occurs in asteroids but isn't
really common on the earth and so this
what seemed like a completely crazy
Theory actually turned out to be true
and it turned out 65 million years ago
there was this asteroid that hit the
earth near the Gulf of Mexico I guess
and sort of threw up a bunch of dust or
so this is kind of relevant if you if
you're interested in kind of global
warming climate change things like that
the fact that it's possible to have a
bunch of dust thrown into the upper
atmosphere that will cover the Sun and
cool things down it's kind of
interesting it's kind of bad if you're a
dinosaur and you don't get to you know
make a fire and keep warm and so on um
but that's um that's kind of the seems
to have been the story of what happened
and and it's interesting that they've
been at several times in the history of
the earth there have been these asteroid
impacts it's it's something these days
one of the questions is can we tell if
there's going to be an asteroid that
collides with the earth and there are
various efforts to watch for asteroids
it's actually an interesting math
problem because you see an asteroid it's
on a certain orbit you have to compute
you have to solve these differential
equations to work out you know will the
asteroids orbit in fact intersect with
the orbit of the earth and it's possible
to do that these days and we'll know if
there's any serious risk of that the
question of what you do whether you can
go and send a spacecraft and nudge the
asteroid a little bit out of the way
there's pretty decent evidence that that
should be possible um so I don't think
we're not going to have an asteroid I
don't think cause us trouble but there
are other kinds of questions that came
up like it seemed
like if you look at the history of life
on Earth there seem to have been these
periodic extinctions that have happened
where a large fraction of species that
existed went extinct and one of them
happened at this KT boundary the
cretaceous-tertiary boundary 65 million
years ago there were other ones that had
happened previously there was one I
think in the Cambrian period 250 million
years ago maybe um that was fairly
dramatic and possibly they're all
associated with asteroid impacts and
there was sort of a theory for a while
that I don't think turned out to be
correct that maybe there are sort of
just a whole crowd of asteroids that are
sort of orbiting around in the solar
system and that every so often every 60
million years or something that there'd
be a bunch of them near the earth that
doesn't seem to be true it seems to be
more of a random kind of thing